identity politics which seemingly has
become the cultural issue and I think
almost every almost every one of the
policy issues is now rooted in identity
politics so I think you can argue that
the way we talk about free college is
somehow rude and identity politics
certainly integration is rooted in
identity politics that we we're sadly
whittling everyone down - you're an
Asian man and I must have some judgment
on you because of that and this person's
Y in this person's black and this
person's Muslim etc etc do you view
identity I've heard you talk about it a
little bit actually but do you view
identity politics as positive that's
dangerous as a tool for something i IE
under it's like a lot of the other
things you've been talking about it's
like I understand the sentiment and
ideas around identity politics I don't
think it's a great way to try and build
consensus or bring people together or
get big policies across the finish line
and I think it's a kind of stupid way to
try and win elections and so I think the
democratic party needs to try and
gravitate away from identity politics
and towards things that would actually
bridge the gap so that's one of my
missions during this campaign is to make
that case to say look I understand
people have different experiences I've
had different experiences but if we're
gonna solve some of these problems we
have to emphasize the things that will
bring us together and not the things
that are going to make us seem like
we're living different lives so that
must be pretty sad for you to see how
far the Democratic Party has gone in on
this or at least some of the other
candidates that you're gonna be standing
on stage with photographers yeah it's
been really interesting for me because
like I'm I was you know it's like I've
been like a you know Democrat and like I
thought it's like hey it's like I'm just
like you guys like and but the odd thing
is they I don't mean the people on stage
necessary but they the people that buy
into these ideas would look at you and
go okay well he's Asian and and because
of the way agents are socioeconomic
successful in families stay together and
all these things your markers of
identity are the ones that get punished
I mean obviously out I'm sure I don't
have to tell you about what happened
with Harvard and the Asian students that
they wanted to deflate the numbers on
and it's like no one gave your parents
from Taiwan anything when they got here
but they want you to be punished because
they work hard and now you work hard
well you know it's like the Asian
American identity certainly it's got
like its own distinct place and like
that sort of like you know identity
hierarchy I suppose I would say a very
precarious place unfortunately but like
that the case I'm making is like look my
parents came here to to have a better
life for me and my brother and it's
worked and now I'm trying to give back
and that's you know been my experience
as an American I'm a very proud American
and I want to try and make this country
stronger so that my kids and and you
know other people's kids grow up in a
country that we're all so excited about
and we do not have that much time to
make that happen because things are
coming apart very quickly
[Music]